the world will be watching st. Louis
the best in the US
the best in the world
only one will be king
the sink your cup
we have reached round five of the sink
filled cup here in st. Louis and this is
going to be one of the most exciting
days in American chess history we've got
a critical matchup between Nakamura and
Carlson and we have Garry Kasparov
joining us on the show later in the hour
an exciting day in store for sure that's
right I'm Jennifer chehade this is Grand
Master yasir Sarah Juan and we also have
a little recap from yesterday where the
tournament really completely changed
character with Carlson leapfrogging over
Nakamura well today you saw the leaders
trying to extend their lead Nakamura
trying to beat Aronian played very risky
chess and in the end he was ground down
and very disgusted by the loss he had
Aronian on the other hand it was quite
pleased with the result of this game so
to see such top players have divergent
opinions as humorous yeah yeah wow I
guess I was right in the other match up
world number one Magnus Carlsen needing
a win to take the lead push for over
five hours and finally defeated the US
Champion gata kamsky I did not play in
the best way possible at all at some
point I lost control but fortunately it
was enough
well now the leaders have switched roles
first it was Carlson pursuing now it's
Nakamura pursuing him in this critical
matchup Nakamura has never defeated
Carlson and we know Nakamura as a big
fighter though he's always looking to
win games yesterday didn't work out for
him but today he hopes things go
differently Carlson or the other hand
plays to the death whatever color he has
he has been quoted as saying that it's
inexcusable in fact there's simply no
excuse for not playing out the games he
thinks that draws should be eliminated
that is the draw offer so we expect to
see an intense fight from those two in
the other match up with Aronian and calm
ski cos he's not playing well and
Aronian finally won a big game so he's
back in the thick of things so expect
today's round 5 to be an exciting fight
back to you jenna yes let's take a look
at the standings after four rounds as we
mentioned before we had a little bit of
a leap frog Carlson now the number one
player in the world number one player in
history with three points in the lead
half a point ahead of his rival he's
playing today Nakamura with two and a
half Aronian back to an even score after
a horrible round one blunder and poor
gata kamsky looking still for his first
victory
and our matchups Carlson rather nakamura
playing the white pieces against Carlson
Nakamura you know going to try to try to
squeeze something out here he's played a
lot of games against Carlsen with the
white pieces and he's tried a lot of
different things everyone's wondering
what is he going to do today is he gonna
go for beef or g4 and we will find out
for quite soon and then we also have our
game between aronian playing white again
so he's getting too white to row against
gata kamsky and uronian will need to win
this game if he has any hope of grabbing
the same kyoka and we are actually
getting some moves in one of the biggest
moves that we saw so far is that
Nakamura has brought back to sunglasses
oh yes and on that is not that shocking
considering the fact that he want he
didn't win that game but he was on the
better side of a draw with black against
the top player in the world so that is
cool and nah he does look sharp with
them yeah and the distance there it
looks like a good bodyguard huh and we
already yeah he mused all he really need
to do is protect himself from himself
even that Gomorrah sometimes he plays a
he just plays fantastic chest but
especially when he was younger and not
such an elite player he would sometimes
just be a little bit to go wild with
some of his choices but you predicted
correctly the opening yesterday you
thought that we would see Roy lopez from
nakamura but that I'm like against ghana
kamsky got a calm ski also played the
royal PES against Carlson yesterday and
that was an exchange variation you
thought that we would see something more
topical and you were right but Carlson
was the first one to differ so if we
remember yesterday he played a six
against kamsky inviting gotta to play
into you know some traditional clothes
lines instead got immediately captured
on c6 we had the exchange Rui exactly
and surprisingly Carl's him one just a
an attacking game with Queens off the
board yeah it was pretty impressive yes
especially that opening is supposed to
be so quiet and no threats to White's
king but white skin came
pressure and eventually got a comp ski
lost today Magnus has deviated as early
as the fourth move and plague Knight f6
the bird what we call the Berlin defense
in the rural Lopez the main line has
continued castles Knight takes e4 d4
Knight d6 this trade of Queens this
queenless middlegame position has become
extremely topical at the most elite
professional levels black loses the
privilege of castling but in return gets
the two bishops and white the theory
holds that white has the better of it
but there's a lot of dynamic
possibilities for the black player as
well so it's not just play on one goal
no it's likely that we get this but it's
not a hundred percent there are some
anti Berlin type variations where I can
go for something else right there's a
possible rookie one which doesn't have
that great of a theoretical reputation
right but you also even play some kind
of d3 system which is another kind of
anti Berlin for those of you who are
really hoping that a queen stay on the
board in his room but honestly even with
Queens off the board we do see the main
line of the Berlin these two fighting
players are not going to agree to a draw
quickly Nakamura needs to fight for a
win to win the sink yoga precisely he
has no incentive to go for a draw and as
we heard from Magnus earlier he also
wants to uh play it out I mean he's here
in many ways to practice for his world
championship match isn't about seventy
thousand dollars in the same field cup
that's part of it but another big honor
for st. Louis is that this is his
training round absolutely absolutely he
wants to show that he's going to be in
great form for his world championship
match in November and Chennai and after
some hesitation whether or not he wanted
to do an anti Berlin as you said with d2
d3 he Caro did decide to Castle and very
quickly Magnus captured this pawn on e4
Knight takes e4 and like you said there
is this move rookie one but that is
really getting played out that it's that
the position after night d6 Knight takes
e4 e5 is considered to take yeah there's
just too many trades it's too easy for
black I mean this is a great choice for
an amateur player who prefers to have
Queens on the board and likes attacking
positions but at the level of knock more
on Carl's and they just can't afford to
give up the advantage of being white
even if it means the position that would
technically suit their style more you
know they had I think they kind of at
that level you can't choose something
that's equal just because you like it
right no you have to at the highest
level gain some type of an advantage
coming out of the opening with white and
I'm not quite sure looks like oh yeah I
think he did play rook e1 very hard to
tell that'll work that'll be extremely
interesting and you know it would be
great that we're getting Garry Kasparov
on the line in the after the break with
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley because of
course Gary has unpleasant memories of
the sofa yes he does and yet I'm sure
I'll have lots of insight into why of
course and decide the place is opening
now and whether it was a good choice how
nakamura defended against it and I
decided against it he's white but he
didn't play work to e1 write amazing
very interesting and of course Nakamura
could have expected that this was one of
the lines that Carlson might play so I
think that's why he didn't really take a
lot of time he decided that this is what
he was gonna do you didn't want to trade
queens and for the many Nakamura fans
out there that's why why we like him yes
indeed but at the same time this choice
of rookie one really pardon me is
ducking the main line and Vladimir
Kramnik amongst many other people have
shown that after rookie one very very
difficult for white gain an edge we do
have the move Bishop e7 and now this
bishop on b5 is a target for the night
and white had to use the tempo to
retreat his bishop now I thought there
were some lines in
variation where white actually moved the
Bishop to d3 yes that's saying that's it
in line with 95 right no you could also
in this particular moment play Bishop d3
you're stepping in front of the default
deep on you drive everybody you got
cheapos try to check mate you mean it's
kind of like yeah I've seen this kind of
a cheapo idea here in this line with
rookie 3 or overnight to brilliant
occasionally why it gets a little attack
but again somebody like Carlson it's
probably not heart out you mean if you
go berserk right away something like
this yeah you can go berserk and I it
doesn't quite work because let's let's
take a look and show why it doesn't
quite work I think it may be [ __ ] about
f6 and g6 will get mated but you have to
take only five and the problem is if you
if you um if you try to kick on c6 they
can take with the deep on and then the
bishop guards h3 yes it's all clear you
can't really get it all in quite like
you need to write just to point out like
in this position if you try to toss in
this knight c6 move with the idea of
what you were just mentioning Rover this
Bishop protects that square h 3 so
there's no no follow-through there's no
attack if you play rookie three right
away Knight takes you go over here with
the threat of checkmate on this square
or even checkmate on the h eight square
black makes room for his King just to
step out and the checks are ineffective
and your two pieces down oh well yeah
and then the end this is this is why
Nakamura we're treating this [ __ ] up to
f1 directly in such a symmetrical
position you do wonder how is he gonna
get something with right here and why
did he is screw the me
nine of the Bruins so a very interesting
opening decision by Nakamura let's take
a look at our other game today to see
what happened on the board in a row
neons game against kamsky exactly and we
have a repeat of the previous game that
Aronian had white against Magnus Carlsen
okay well interesting psychological
choice by kamsky he saw that Carlson got
a very good position with black it's a
so he decided to follow suit and play
the Dutch and in our interview with a
mangas Carlson after the game he said
that he chose the Dutch because he
thought that aronian wasn't as
comfortable with the Dutch as he was
without their openings indeed and he got
a very good game as we saw in that
matchup although it was a draw it like a
game black on the fighting side of the
draw which is never a good thing for
your white opening exactly Magnus got an
advantage very early with the black
pieces so d4f 5c for Knight f6 93 d6
night of 3g six so-called Leningrad
Dutch now traditionally everybody has
felt that the proper treatment in this
position is to play g3 and feeing shadow
the King's Bishop Aronian however stuck
to his guns and played the move Bishop
f4 Bishop g7 III I believe has been
played indeed and now we're waiting for
God had to play in that previous game
that we've been citing where Aronian was
white and Magnus was black that game had
gone castles Bishop e2 knight c6 castles
and i believe it was 94 at this moment
that led to a good game for Magnus as
black so certainly Aronian will have
LaVon will have come with a better
development from White's point of view
he may be thinking
that he should just cut out this
possibility of Knight f6 to e4 by
playing in early Queen D 1 2 C 2 and
we'll see how he has prepared his
opening for today yeah and as usual
looks like we've got two pretty exciting
games in store it's been pretty
astonishing how how combative these
games have been I was worried about just
two games you know maybe there would be
a little dry the drawers would be
relatively quick but of course we have
the 30 move draw rule but even then even
so sometimes you can get a game that
doesn't have a lot of juice to it yeah
but that's been to the contrary every
single round totally thrilling all the
games have a great content yes that's
right and we've got Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley for some thoughts on today's
openings well Jen it's so often you see
an opening start off slowly and you
think all these guys is just trying to
draw and then it suddenly bills and
explodes into something super exciting
and I pulled up a game between Nakamura
and Carlson one of the recent whites
that Nakamura had in the London classic
in 2012 and in this position Nakamura
way the move of c3 now we know the open
Sicilian is the move d 4 immediately and
get into potentially wild positions but
here you play the move c3 and the game
built rather built rather slowly I want
to go to later in the game in this
moment here after this position arose
and nakamura play the move rookie a to
know again we said slow build slow
position c3 Sicilian right wrong in this
moment Carson play the move Knight takes
be for sacrificing his night for two
pawns and after this capture Knight
takes back again hitting the rook alandi
to it moved into work on 82 and moved to
d2 and then rook takes on d3 not quite
an exchange sacrifice because of this
full trade here and a massive piece is
coming off the board and then rook to d8
attacking the Queen through to the rook
the Queen's Rob back and yet another
trade happen and then he continued with
another trade Bishop takes f 3 now the
Queen can capture because of the pain of
the bishop on c1 so not good morning to
take back with the pawn
and then the capture on e5 which was the
whole point of this extended combination
to get three pawns for the piece the
wrecked King side position ended up
playing itself out into a draw after a
terrific fight it shows that even when
you have positions that start off quiet
they can explode at any moment into
something super exciting so we're
expecting something like that to happen
in today's round back to you guys let's
take a look at Nakamura and Carlson's
previous matchups as we mentioned before
in the show always a tough player for
Nakamura he's actually lost a seven
games against him and then we've got 13
draws and that's in classical time
controls and although Magnus Carlsen is
a top player in the world and has a
pretty good score against most flyers
that's even larger than you would
imagine yeah it's completely off the
chart as far as their rating is
concerned having a plus to score might
have been more normal considering their
rating difference Magnus being a
favorite whenever they play but plus 7
no that's that's that's crazy no in this
for me has done pretty well he won he
drew that game with black where he was
better yes so that was pretty impressive
and after the game that was the one
where he trotted out the sunglasses for
the first time he tweeted at GM hikaru
no hypnotism better chess so that was a
kind of interesting r America we're not
sure if he's saying that uh Magnus
hypnotizes him or if he's hypnotizing
Magnus with his sunglasses but one way
or the other he decided to stick with it
yes well whatever works gets repeated
let's see what it seems like they're
making a lot of moves now he's certainly
are interesting because on one hand I'm
excited to see that Nakamura kept Queens
on the board but any other there is a
hunter there is a high percentage of
drawers in this line just because of the
large quantity of trades and now it
Tatiana's it almost looks like they're
playing blitz is this yeah yeah there
wasn't seem real how could this be well
there was a pause for the move
he won so many moves right there was a
pause for the move rookie won by Hikaru
and a pause by Magnus to decide whether
or not he wanted to trade right away on
e5 he did exchange and then after the
move castles Knight c3 developing
bringing the pieces off the back rank
preparing to play night to d5 where the
night would be very well placed here and
here Magnus thought a little bit but
then decided on his reaction which was
night on d6 drop back to e8 he's losing
some time but he has an idea of setting
up c7c 6 d-7 d5 in the center and that
is what he is playing for so we had to
move 95 attacking the bishop on e 7
Magnus moved his bishop to d6 with a
counter-attack against the rook on e5
the rook dropped back to e1 just um oops
dropped back to you all back Noah
prayers of Rovers right and a black
Queen c6 c7 c6 attacking the knight
Knight III hoping to perhaps happen to a
five right Magnus anticipating that and
also trying to push his deep on forward
plays Bishop dc-7 exactly and the night
did hop nonetheless to the FI square so
what Hikaru has in mind is to bring his
night invade with 97 check and take this
Bishop winning the two bishops even
though it hasn't developed a carros
spending a lot of time and after night a
lot of time in terms of the chess game
as we see they're basically blitzing out
these moves so all well within their
preparation I mean it looked like they
were playing what's there for a minute
exam it was all these kind of rather for
she moves not technically for us in that
material wouldn't be lost if they can do
it but just completely logical d 597
check they see it right so we can sum up
the results of the opening
follows white has won the long-term
advantage of the two bishops but because
the pawn structure is so symmetrical
it's very hard for the first player to
prove an advantage and on the other hand
notice that all of whites pieces each
and every single one of them are on the
first rank so this gives a Magnus the
time he needs to bring his pieces out I
never saw a pair official thing you
didn't like I like the pair of bishops
but in this particular case I just see
very easy play for Magnus he's going to
bring his Knight to f6 he's very likely
to bring his queen to d6 with with a
checkmating threat by the way in passing
and then he's just going to challenge
the e-file so in this specific moment
I'd say White's advantage is so small as
to be nearly minuscule right so you'd
still prefer white but you don't think
it's quite enough considering that he
had the first move exactly and in it
looks like Nakamura has played g3 in
this position right d3 had been played
previously so it looks like g3 is that
was played by night eh against Kramnik
and Dortmund just a couple months ago
right that mean was a draw and so
nakamura playing the first new movie
game with g3 right so in that game
between a cod in a dish and vladimir
kramnik this is the precedent d2 d3
which makes perfect sense you open up at
the diagonal for your Bishop Hikaru my
small new ones he was played later in
that game anyway exactly it's it's a
move you're you're you're likely to be
provoked to play but just to stop
because you don't have any defenders
over there normally you would have a
knight on f3 so it's not as much to try
to fee and get all the bishop you don't
really need your bishop on g2 it's more
just to you know provoked to stop
possible Queen 84 type threats that
could come later into the decision right
and anticipate that we spoke about Queen
d6 with a battery so g2 g3 is a
prophylactic move
anticipation of black making the threat
but the reason why I think Hikaru was
specifically attracted to this move g3
let's just put a move for black for a
moment on the board Knight f6 I think he
liked this idea as opposed to putting
his Bishop on g2 as we know we loved the
fianchetto bishop and now we're fighting
on so much Brad exactly here on h3 it
does have the advantage of gaining a
tempo against that rook and if we just
play the further move repeat for a
moment now comes the move d2 d3 queen d
6 this is Hikaru's idea that he'll get a
tempo against the Queen and since that
Bishop is no longer defended by the rook
Magnus would have to retreat right so
Magnus wouldn't play Queen the d610 is
hard for him to connect his rocks
because the Queen doesn't have d7 or d6
available so that that makes you wonder
yeah okay so instead you want to play
rook to e8 that's right just finish your
development in that way that's right and
the nice purpose of them smooth rook e8
as it does support the e5 square so this
Bishop could eventually come to the
center and put pressure on this pawn on
be too but now I mean you're starting
the book likewise position a little bit
better I mean I like the princess Bishop
g5 puts a little bit of pressure back
now we're actually threatening rook
takes you yay because you'd have to
either take with a night losing a queen
or take with the Queen destroying your
pawn structure allowing the double pawns
and maybe next move I'll play Queen f3
and you know adds more pressure to that
idea well if you take obviously I have
to recapture yeah and now after eight
six we wish that we didn't have that
plan on G right the bishop would have to
drop back I got me this time we could
look at this rage foreign Queen d2 but
we would probably end up rejecting it
right so we always try to sacrifice our
pieces on this broadcast right cuz we
can take out moves back if they don't
work out that's right so why just needs
like one more gamble and his advantage
would be
kind of significant right like if you
get d3 and Bishop t5n right before you
got a chance to play rikiei then you'd
be super cramped right so he's kind of
just like so close to having something
big but not quite of course it seems
that this is clearly preparation yes not
something he's coming up with a reward
otherwise he wouldn't be playing so
quickly so it was preparation it means
that he thinks it's pretty good right uh
by the way Magnus took a different
approach which was quite extraordinary
to my eyes he didn't bring his Knight to
f6 bringing his night off the back rang
instead after this move g3 he chose the
move Knight d6 obviously Magnus feels
that his night is better placed on this
square d 6 giving him a little bit more
flexibility in terms of where that night
might go as well as keeping the option
of Queen f6 open let's see a few moves
after save Bishop a h3 route d 3 this is
maybe the point of Magnus's preparation
is to make it a little bit difficult for
white to develop his Queen side
specifically the bishop on c1 know is
there any way maybe Macklemore we
consider keen can only use other Bishop
because I do feel that that long
diagonal seems kind of juicy she does
one of the reasons that he played g 30
it still might play Bishop age three but
my ideas maybe i'll play d3 it's a
moment alright and then you your queen
f6 would not view to impactful because I
would just play work to be one and blame
should be two anyway uh well I think
Queen f6 is a very nice tempo first of
all yes you could play with me one you
could play Bishop e3 if you'd like but
after either rook me wanna Bishop e3 I
think this counter attack that's her
94th coming yes you're giving black the
opportunity to gain the initiative and I
don't think he car is going to be very
attract it's a good point yet with our
Connie 1f to his tender now let's take a
look at the current world
rankings as we watch the top players in
the world in the US face off here at the
single cup in st. Louis these are up to
date rankings with all the games that
have been played so far in this infield
cup we've got Carlson number one Aronian
and number two I think he had actually
dropped down to number three but after
his win yesterday he bounced back right
in Nakamura in fists he was in fourth
before he's lost yesterday that was an
all-time high for him so really exciting
for enough Mora fans right but still
number 5 not bad and Dada cams can be of
course having a terrible tournament and
that dropped him down quite a number of
places in the world rankings especially
for somebody like gotta the rankings are
even more clumped together there in like
nineteen third 15th so a win or a loss
can really leapfrog employed a numbered
spot absolutely because the pack at the
very top is so tight a single win or
loss can really cost you a lot of places
in the world's rankings exactly i mean
i've seen gotta how good tournament and
be ten in the world again not you know
he has been up there even this year yes
um and we have a grandmaster maurice
ashley for some thoughts on aronian
kamsky yes Jen we have a novelty alert
in the game against a game between
Aronian and calm ski it seemed as though
kamsky was the one using the
psychological ploy of repeating an
opening that aronia had a tough time
against when he played against Carlson
earlier in the tournament in round two
and so we have this Dutch defense on the
board and in this position we see that
this Bishop and is on f4 which is
somewhat unusual to see in this opening
well in that game against Carlson
Aronian play the move castles in this
moment and we saw Carlson played this
very nice move Knight to e4 and this
allowed him to very quickly play e5 and
he had white on the ropes pretty quickly
he didn't manage to win the game but
certainly is not something that Aronian
wanted to repeat we go back to this
position in this game against kamsky
Aronian had apparently improved on this
game against Carlson already and he has
played the move Bishop back to g3
keeping
Bishop out of the reach of the e pawn
and so this small nuance maybe he's
prepared it beforehand just in case comp
ski played the move but at any rate com
skis now thinking about what to do about
this new move and in fact come ski has
moved and he's played the groove 86 it
seems on the board and leaving aronian
to consider the position back to you
guys thank you so number of novelties in
town and both of them occurring on the
g3 square yeah and they're they're small
they're very subtle very nuanced little
moves to change the theoretical debate
let's just take a look at why aronian
played this move Bishop g3 it's it's
surprising but that this bishop on f4
might actually beat a tactical target in
the game between Magnus after the move
castles 94 Aronian as white could not
have captured on the e4 square because
now this Bishop is a tactical target for
the rook the moment the night moves then
black has this capture Knight takes d4
and if we take the night well we'd lose
our bishop in no time for kamikaze on
Bishop takes c6 because you have been
unable to remove night AC to check
exactly so what aronian did is he
dropped back with his bishop prior to
castling so he wanted to rule out this
move 94 now there's a big difference 94
no longer works very nicely for black
because after the trade the night comes
back and it turns out this pawn on e4 is
going to be vulnerable and there is no
Knight takes d4 because the bishop is
now safe on the G 3 squared so that was
why we didn't seem night efore by gotta
but we saw this little bit surprising
move h7 h6 instead this move deserves a
little explanation
so in this position we understand that
night efore is no longer good how about
night h5 simply going after this Bishop
on g3 I think what lavona had in mind
was the move Bishop age for preventing
night takes g3 and in case of h6 with
the idea of g5 to trap the bishop then
White has 92 attacking the knight on h 5
and black cannot win the two bishop
that's right this is some really precise
and important move order staff here so
starting with h 6 now opening the idea
985 and since we've already moved the
Bishop to d3 moves like 83 or h4 seem
kind of like they're off beat right
because we wanted to escape our Bishop
with age 3 then we would probably wanted
to put the bishop on h2 that's right so
uh now LaVon thinking and for those of
you who are joining us for the first
time well what took you so long yes
exactly welcome we like to welcome you
here to the beautiful st. Louis chess
club right across the street we also
have the world chess hall of fame with a
number of gorgeous chess sets and art
inspired chess exhibits rather chess
exhibits inspired by art the largest
test piece in the world and that's a
something to lots of let the people to
say you even after they're drinking in
the bars they go and they pose next to
the largest touch piece it's really cool
to see we had Tom some facts about the
st. Louis chess club was founded in 2007
a mecca for chess in the United States
and the world and who's more than 80
tournaments per year were heavily
focused on education and youth outreach
you want to get on all the young
students in st. Louis playing our
beautiful game and we've also been home
to the US Championship and US women's
chess championships since 2009
and thanks to the sink fields for
founding this club and to all the staff
here for making this event runs smoothly
it's always a pleasure to come out and
people see the photos and they read
about it and I notice it when they come
here at all right wow it really is as
good as I thought it was going to be
right admit meets your expectations
while those US Championships the last
few ones the best tournaments in the in
the nation by far of course and now
pardon me with a sink real Cup now we're
branching into an elite elite
tournaments and I also wanted to add one
further thought to the graphic there
about the same about the club is we're
going into five hundred schools we have
more than about 36 coaches that we send
to all of those schools and if you just
say well at each school we impact the
lives of say ten kids that would mean
5,000 children each year are being
exposed to chest here in the st. Louis
area so very impressive outreach that we
have it's really fantastic have both
ends of it the elite chest and then also
just teaching kids to play and make
their lives a little bit more fun
especially in school the kids always
like it when they get the you know do a
little bit of chest well let's play it's
fun and you're learning at the same time
what could be sweeter we see some kids
here in the audience today of course
it's a weekend so the club is mobbed and
I know everybody's just like trying to
plot how they can get Magnus crossings
autograph hey get have been in between
loose I isn't really he's a really nice
kid but um that being said I mean he's
such a nice kid but you got it sometimes
say like he has limited time right so
all the people who want photos with him
and autographs with him they uh they
have to have to be lucky basically right
well we did have a signing session I'm
good first day nobody got turned away
that's what I was pretty awesome yeah
anybody had tickets got their signature
and photos posed it was very impressive
at the we have a very significant
development in game in our big game not
in Mora Carlson as we know Magnus
Carlsen with black leads the field by
half a point
in fact he leads hikaru by half a point
and we did see this move Bishop h3 as
expected the bishop you mentioned it
would be biting on granite on this
diagonal g2 and g3 is just blocking the
deep on and just the not enough for
somebody like Carl's and it's more like
a cheapo type move so instead of Bishop
h3 gaining a temple against the rock yes
and rather than move his rook away and
just getting out of that threat Magnus's
played f7f 5 a really bold move that
basically says hey listen I want to play
f5f for in the very near future and I
want to be on the attack I want the
initiative very interesting I just
looking at looking at the position
aesthetically without calculating
anything yet I like this model like I
like the way that Magnus seems like he
might coordinate something and actually
if I if Macklemore doesn't find precise
moves even get any initiative and that's
what we saw yesterday happen against
kamsky right and you gotta love about
crossing even though he's not some you
know guy who tries to out there he his
opponent he does come up with ways to
win with both pieces and put pressure on
his opponent even with black even with
black as we're seeing right now that fri
like a you I don't know I i well I'm not
sure I always remember the fond words of
Viktor Korchnoi pawns do not move
backwards oh yeah my dad when he was
teaching my brother and I chassis you're
just not to play off our eyes really no
that's that one Iron Mike you have a
good dad you're very very lucky young
lady f5 well let's imagine d2 d3 just
preparing to develop our Bishop and
stopping f4 is the stopping the
potential down the road friend right now
it's pinder for and let's just imagine
the move Queen f6 which we expected
earlier just putting pressure on the
queenside
and now we have let's say a move like c2
c3 the real question is how is Magnus
going to get in this break f5f for
without allowing Bishop takes h3 takes
z8 I think he's going to maybe trying to
make his night on b6 better i don't like
that night on b6 anymore because when
the ones on day three we our dream was
to play 94 well I was thinking maybe
maneuvering it via f7 to g5 okay and
trying to you know see about removing
one of those bishops potentially right
or at least push the bishop back to g2
although to be fair it doesn't look so
bad but just put the [ __ ] of back to
g21 sits there actually looks like that
night on g5 might be kind of awkwardly
placed know and I think it's right on
the button let's say we're just going to
make a not necessarily a bad move just
as just a move for white Bishop d2 but
your idea of night g5 I am very
attracted to this idea because if you
can revoke the bishop to go back then
the move f5f for comes very suddenly
because there's no attack on the rook
and black is set up for pretty promising
King side attack so I like he set up cuz
we're kind of fighting f2 but we also
could play f3 in some positions and get
a positional vine and said absolutely on
the button yes and or if black once he
could capture on g3 and just go Knight
f3 and trade trade trade he has no
problems whatsoever he sold in this line
of play Black has completely sold his
opening problems so this move f7f 5
first instinct was I shied away from the
move a bit on deeper inspection closer
inspection I think it's a good good idea
well it makes sense in that blacks
position was a little bit cramped like
his night is in the way of his bishop
and you know then I can't really go to
e4 and if the Queen goes to f6 its
to you know connect the works at easily
so it does have some kind of even though
it seems weakening you guys I have a
another logical kind of points 20 and
definitely there's some poison here but
white will have to play carefully and
accurately not only to maintain a small
edge but not to fall into a disadvantage
and as we saw yesterday gata kamsky had
what I thought was a fine opening but
just a little slip here and there and
then suddenly Magnus was all over the
position and one in a very clear way
that's right just in a incredible
fighter and just seems to make so many
good moves right right right and long
strings of good moves as they say well
good news is what it's all about in a
2860 oh he's made a lot of them so again
shall we just take a look at this
variation I'm expecting d2 d3 by hikari
you have that on the board oh he did
that Queen I think we have that and then
Queen to f6 III was played and as
mentioned putting the pressure on b2 and
then c2 c3 just to block the diagonal of
the Queen and now here's that moment
where you Jen suggested a fine idea in
my view night f7 and now maybe we can
try to tactically prevent night g5 after
night of 70 right maybe we can try to
i'm looking at the move Queen to h5 and
I see that you can play g6 okay I'm
wondering if that's a weakness that not
more we want to provoke or if it just
helps blacks position okay well queen
age five not only does it prevent
nigeria's also attack the pawn on f5 now
here you are giving me a choice and it's
a tough one I've got I've got a cheapo
trap for you I'm hoping you're gonna
fall for a gin I know yours I know
you're gonna see it but here's my cheapo
I want to play night here so I can catch
yeah I see what you're out there oh yeah
I'm gonna play Bishop g5 oh you're gonna
fall for it oh you're a great sport you
really are
sport so the idea is you're attacking my
queen and it looks like the bishop is
adequately defended but here we have the
old nite nite fork I'll take the bishop
you'll take my queen and there we see it
check to the White King and after King
Mo's night takes what black wins apiece
and the game definitely one of the one
of those like kind of typical little
chess tactics queen sacrifice if you
look in your combinations book you'll
find hundreds of variations on this
theme but sometimes it's hard for
amateur players to see that over the
board even if they can find it a good
book but it's a nice setup they're so
green age 5 you're right the question
that you are asking and I think it's a
very salient question is this move g7 g6
is that to weakening in other words is
this diagonal it's going to be like a
magnet for whites dark squared Bishop
hard to say still a lot of play ahead in
this game and we do have a number of
special guest for you today in addition
to having Garry Kasparov leader in the
show yes we have one of the illustrious
grandmasters from Webster University
Wesley so and he is with Maurice Ashley
thanks then thanks Jen with Grandmaster
Wesley so all of 19 years old studying
in his second year at webster university
welcome to the show Wesley thank you now
you're over 2700 and when you were 14
years old you became a grandmaster the
eighth youngest Grandmaster in history
now you're watching these players how
does it feel to have a tournament like
this this close to you and you're not
even able to play in it and I don't mind
but they certainly will have the biggest
sermons I've ever followed it is turning
the biggest tournament in us and I'm
very happy that it's made in st. Louis
just confirms the fact that st. Louis as
one of the top cities for chess in the
United States and I'm very happy to be
here now the games what do you think
about the quality of the games your 2700
player your number 39 in the world as of
right now what do you think what the
quality is you've been
these games yeah I'm in following the
tournament yeah the games are very good
I've been following mostly Carlson's
games played a really good game
yesterday against Gonski and where he
won with black and so for the games
today I'm still not sure what their
souls are gonna be still basically
they're just basically starting are you
surprised by by Hikaru's choice of
opening with this very quiet variation
of the Ray Lopez that normally doesn't
promise any real advantage yeah I
thought I thought Carlson made a good
opening choice today because basically
sup a point ahead and nakamura has to
win and I think the Berlin is a good
option I guess there and there's not
much choice against the Berlin these
days I mean if you don't play okay one
more fight be able to play d4 but
crossing is very good in this end games
so I think Nakamura will still try to
push from this position have you ever
had trouble against a player the way
Nakamura seems to have trouble against
Carlson well you just don't seem to have
the breakthrough against them and then
what do you do in order to play against
a player who we see Nakamura with
sunglasses on maybe trying to rate the
psychological grip this guy has on him
oh yeah I think like the like Nam wear
ties with psychologically right and
yourself have you ever had this
experience with a player who just seems
to beat you every game yeah I had some
problems with mic on with my colleagues
like for example humanish gear or GM car
wanna like they are on my age so I'm
having some trouble playing against them
sometimes but i guess the simplest thing
to do is just to prepare for them just
to prepare harder for them they're even
harder what are your aspirations as far
as becoming world champion I know you're
a student now second year of college you
thinking I mean you're 19 are you
thinking maybe one day you could break
through and become the top layer in the
world oh well I'm turning 20 a month I'm
not done but ah yeah I'm glad the st.
Louis has helped me to improve a lot of
a chess player because Webster also has
a lot of good players it allows me to
work harder as for any aspirations well
I think I'll just play chess is hard to
foresee
what I can achieve but I'm very glad
that for that like two days ago cross
and visited Webster so it was a great
opportunity for me and as for my goals
and I have um some tournaments coming up
I have to turn strong tournaments coming
in Netherland so it depends how i do
that term is and indeed well we wish you
best of luck with your chest career and
your studies at webster and everything
else you aspire to do thank you very
much one thing I have to face like I'm
it's a little strange or onion decided
to play bf4 again against the Dutch
today I'm not totally sure if that's the
best idea but okay throwing a little jab
at the end there aronian well we thank
grandmaster wesley snow Wesley so one of
the top teams in the world at only 19 he
told me about to turn 20 certainly a
fine player back to you jenna yet Thank
You Maurice yeah it's wonderful to see
all visa Grandmaster guess it's like you
come to the club and you know there's
just so many stars walking around it's
really exciting right there's also a lot
of those strong players from Lindenwood
he's around and I just never know who
you're gonna see here at the ziegfeld
cup well and of course one of the
colleagues that goes to Webster Liam
them from Vietnam he was actually a
reserve player in case something had
happened to one of the poor players here
in the tournament Liam was ready to step
right in and say okay fine young man
Wesley I known him since he was a young
teen and he's just developed
tremendously he's a great talent from
the Philippines the strongest Philippine
no player since the legend eugenia Tory
oh that's right and he's only 19 and
just a nice modest man I like that the
end he said one more thing one more
thing what is levon aronian
sigh now right yes I thought he's gonna
say hey hello mom yeah right right right
no Jennifer you know something like
doesn't think he's so passionate about
chess that you know he's watching these
games and like wait a minute yeah wait a
minute you get really you know you get
really involved and it's nice that um
you know Carlson visited I think like
four even even for a player that strong
mm-hmm having that extra inspiration of
its diwana man & Carlson visiting and
meeting Amy it's just like I'm sure you
met crossing before but you know it's
it's right exciting it makes you think
like well if I gained like another 20
points cuz right now Wesley is over 2700
absolutely no I gained another 50 points
maybe I'll get invited you know so
nicely you can be a real motivator right
on right on would be just before we do
leave this game and go to switch to the
camp ski game rook c8 e8 was played not
that night have said a move rather just
very strategically challenging white for
control over the e-file just a nice
simple solid move by magnus carlsen and
again he looks like he sold most of his
opening problems yeah what do you think
it Nakamura is now going to do about his
bishop on he want ibly develop it the
question is where should he play the
move Bishop f4 and inset in one sense
provoked g5 or should he just be a
little bit more modest and play Bishop d
to Bishop e3 is another possibility
China
you